[Music]
study you're with me on this one right
oh your strength gives me strength
when the movie was gonna come out we had
no no idea what it was gonna be is it is
a comedy is it an action picture is it
an adventure about all of it none of it
I can still hear Rachel going oh no
they're going to confiscate our Equity
cards
what does that even mean did we do it
wrong did we chew up the scenery too
much yeah I know I did but
[Music]
School dies
in 10 years nobody's going to remember
any of this
you'll still be a goddamn Jew
you'll still be a prick School Ties was
my first feature film
I thought it was also going to be my
last one for all I knew so each day is
one that I can remember something unique
about in all the time that I've been
lucky enough to be making movies so much
if it becomes a blur but because it was
uh such
um an opportunity for a 22 23 year old
actor the gravity of it none of it was
lost on me but I had to try to put that
out of mind because I hadn't really had
no frame of reference for what pressure
felt like or didn't feel like I didn't
know it was a cast that was introducing
a lot of new actors that we would see
coming up in the 90s like Matt Ben Chris
it was sort of the diner model is what
we were told my screen test for it was
with Matt and I knew that I needed to
match pitch with him I wasn't really
certain how working for camera
differentiated from what I was
accustomed to having just at the time my
life come out of training in a
conservatory I knew that I needed to
size things down you're not playing to
the last row and I also knew that if I
just listened to what Matt was saying I
was getting across what needed to be
acted and conveyed and I think that's
because he's such a good actor he makes
you better and I I'm pretty sure that is
a lot to do with why I got the job it's
a film about wanting to belong sooner or
later we've all felt like we've had our
nose pressed up against the glass and we
wanted to be a part of what was on the
inside and there was something keeping
us out and that's who David Green was he
was good enough but he wasn't accepted
because
of its fundamental existence
whether it's by accident or design
because I think I worked almost every
day of the 58 days that I wasn't always
hanging out with the guys after work
because I was always busy off doing
something somewhere else so in a way I
kind of did feel a little bit like The
Outsider wanting to belong with the guys
you know I think the scene is about
being stripped bearer of all of their
colors and shades and armor that we wear
how we identify with one another so it
was appropriate that it was set in a
locker room with teenage boys who when
they disagree lock the door and they
fight shouldn't happen but it happens
the dispute is therefore even uglier
because they're just shaved Apes bashing
on each other cursing at one another it
reveals the Prejudice that we depict in
an appropriate way
George is a good guy
George is just there to help George is
the original babe in the woods
[Music]
how do you act a cartoon character I
don't know I think you have to make him
a person you have to have him have hopes
and aspirations and yes there are there
are rules about George he he will always
win the day because his secret weapon is
dumb luck
I loved working with Leslie Mann and Tom
Thomas Hayden Church I loved working
with all the guys who are the pack
bearers I loved working with the soup
performers in George they were fantastic
I mean these guys have a niche
performance expertise in Simeon Behavior
I mean these are the guys that went on
to do a lot of the Planet of the Apes
movies they were actors performers in
suits with heads you know attached and
Jim Henson's Creature Shop using Cutting
Edge animatronics to make the faces move
and be puppeted remotely it was exciting
to combine all of these different
elements to make a really broad colorful
comedy George the jungle was using CGI
technology in a way that was first just
starting to come into the world of
filmmaking in a way that we we really
take for granted now for instance
George's dog is Shep he's an elephant
and on the day we shot with with Ty the
elephant the shot was designed to have
chap framed up with George and then
George introduces his dog to Ursula and
says this is my dog I think I I went to
scratch the elephant like you would
scratch a dog the CGI guys who were
there to watch scrutinizing with
Hawkeyes about every movement that I
made because if I raise my arm higher
than one picture plane and crossed for
instance the eyes of the elephant across
his eyes they couldn't animate those in
the way that they wanted to to make them
look like they had big Blinky eyebrows
and lashes and if I did it too low then
it you know it would have been another
what hundred thousand dollars if I did
this and it was on budget if I did this
for what we know now and what we started
off with then and going back even
further it's just astonishing to see
what we can do with CGI it all comes
back to the actor the performer
believing in what they're doing because
if they don't then Their audience won't
no matter how much you Gussy it up with
all the bells and whistles I cut my
teeth in George of the Jungle and
learning and learning how to work in a
real broad comedic way and also hone
that into a performance that made sense
to everyone who had to work on it in
post-production to to sell the broad
jokes
[Music]
when my father's work had us traveling
every three four years somewhere new in
the midwest parts of Europe parts of the
Northwest Seattle I went to school in
Toronto whether I felt like I belonged
or didn't I knew that I felt I felt
comfortable in my own skin because when
you're the new guy you got to find a way
to fit in instantly it's just a basic
survival tactic that we all have I I
guess I might have really latched on to
that way of working early on because
there were a series of
knife characters that the babe in the
woods The Fish Out of Water the new guy
the new in town and just trying to fit
in get along my heroes were Buster
Keaton to Bill Irwin in the height of
his clowning career these Savant Poker
Face chaplinesque performances that
Defiance Cinema to this day for the
contribution that they've made was
nothing that was lost on me in the time
that I was in training and certainly
what I remembered about what you needed
to bring to a comedic performance and
the last thing that you need to bring to
a comedic performance is
is the comedy I have no idea how to be
funny I don't know why people may think
I am I am the least funny person I know
I just think you have to believe in
everything you're doing because if you
don't your audience won't it keeps you
honest to do that character I look
towards the innocence of one of those
herding dogs you know that they'll do
what you say and they want to please you
and they want to make sure that they're
included they want to keep everyone
together and they want to get it right
absolutely going to get it right that
was sort of the springboard the spirit
animal that I had in my approach to
playing link the thought out caveman
that and I was pretty wide-eyed about
being in this big Hollywood comedy at
the time that was produced by Disney I
mean I guess I I really just had to show
up to work and feel like wow what is
going on around me and that's what link
is doing all the time why Always where
am I will you be my friend you won't you
will you won't oh we're good we're good
[Music]
The Mummy series
[Applause]
you must not read from the book it's an
action picture wrapped up in a comedy
and a romance and an adventure and a
little bit of a horror and a thrill of
minute kind of rollercoaster popcorn
movie
prove it shots in it we rode our own
camels we wielded our weapons we fought
one another we ran around In the Heat of
the desert of war zazat in Morocco and
all of that gave an authenticity to the
movie that I think made it more globally
appealing than if it had been you know
shot in Arizona or New Mexico the late
great Jim Jacks was adamant about going
to the place where Lawrence of Arabia
was shot I mean the very Place itself is
an important character in the movie it
was thrilling it had a little bit of um
not danger per se but some risk taking
to it also that that felt like well what
will happen today
will we survive Stephen Summers who's
one of his
favorite directions that he would give
was he he'd go ready and
don't suck action threw a bull horn and
we look on things would blow up and
stuff and fall down and animals on fire
and Arnold uh
[Music]
okay we got it
let's do it again we're here
Steven just loves making movies he loved
his job his enthusiasm is infectious I
loved making that movie
it was kind of like coming back to
another semester of college you're like
hey guys
how'd your summer go
get a job
back to Morocco too like hey there's
like you know that's my favorite camel
guy you know like Hi how are you sala
how are you man hey man yeah can I have
my sunglasses back you borrowed them
that one day and you never gave me never
mind
it was just more of the same people
wanted more so we gave him more of the
same we gave more is more lucky ass they
they responded
I'm gonna blow your mind here because I
never met Dwayne until after the
premiere because he was a piece of tape
on a stick we referred to well we were
beating on each me and Arnold were
beating on each other
then they of course put him in in CGI
later and I I know I know be kind the
guys who did the CGI of the Scorpion
King at the premiere they're like hey
Arya great good job you know hey we did
the CG for we did The Scorpion King CG
and they kind of went yeah we needed a
little more time
for a week but they did it was very last
minute I don't know but some of the
charm of it is now when you watch it now
like it could get remastered I guess but
it kind of wouldn't be as fun if you
didn't see this sort of janky video
carrying character of dwindling
and somehow interesting it's just it's
just perfect how it works how things
work out
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go again okay so first of all
look it's an action movie uh Rob Rob
Cohn was directing this one and Steve
Summers was executive producing it so it
had a different Spirit a different
character sadly Rachel didn't come back
I mean I say it selfishly it was it was
its own film and uh it it was set in in
Shanghai in parts of China it was a lot
yeah it was a lot of fighting a lot of
fall down go boom
had been up until that point always
playing every role that I had as
kinetically as possible as physically as
possible as engaged in what the action
of the character was to to get my my
meaning and my point across what can I
say I it caught up with me I had a few
injuries that became another injury like
they said I was playing hurt you know so
I I would wrap up and tape and you know
you do the things you gotta do to get
through with it and we all do that and
I'm happy to but
it it meant that I needed to start
thinking about how to work smart instead
of work hard
around the time I made that movie it was
sort of a fundamental shift in my
Approach
and and now when it comes to doing this
stuff I I just look at the young guys
you're gonna be great in the shot man go
kill it
absolutely got a script
yeah that was great fun are you kidding
Bedazzled
well you know you go out there and you
give 110 and you want to play good and
you know you hope you play good I think
we play pretty good tonight which
version of Elliot do I like the best I
like the guy that he became Harold Ramis
directed this movie as
a parable of a man's Journey towards
Redemption he signs a deal with the
devil all right Devil's gonna trick him
devil does he goes through these seven
different incarnations of himself trying
to better himself be someone that he
isn't the version of himself that he
learns to accept and love most is the
one who he always was but just wasn't
owning it from the very beginning
what do you say we go down to the club
tonight and we uh pick up some chick
hats huh
nice talking to you Bob
now if you if you watch the film in the
last few breaths before credits roll
you'll see that our hero and heroine are
walking out on a bridge on a pier and a
man in an orange robe a monk appears and
that was Harold's nod to his belief of
us being on a spiritual journey he was a
Buddhist at heart himself he believed in
unity and he believed that life is being
a journey and you know we go through
crazy things in life of course and it's
a film that demonstrates that with these
different sequences that are you know
little moviolas in and of themselves I
love this movie because it was it was
almost like it was a morality Fable in
the end you wonder was the devil God all
along and maybe it's Paul part of a
grand plan maybe not but the journey
that he goes on is one of self-discovery
and and that's what I loved about it and
that and I love the makeup and the
variety and working with the stock cast
of characters who keep reappearing
recasting all the different sequences
Liz Hurley is funny as hell she gets the
joke about being the pretty girl in
movies she does and that was like that
was her wardrobe but she get it's a
stock character that she does like no
one else Liz Nails it and then in
between in between setups you go back
and sit in your chair and pull up
needlepoint and have a chat Matthew
mungle designed and created all the
different looks that Elliot went through
Ben Nye Jr was the makeup artist who
collaborated with him and they made each
character a little bit different but you
can always see Elliot somewhere in there
so maybe his nose was a different shape
maybe his hair was a different version
of what of what you saw Elliot as he was
introduced I mean you should still be
able to see the character even though
he's been reincarnated as a Colombian
drug
Espanol
espanol the day that we shot the stuff
it was in Montecito California and at
lunch break um John Cleese who was at
that time living there he was like the
de facto mayor of montesino he came to
visit Harold at lunch and he was asking
like what are you filming today and and
so Harold explained well it's a joke
about a man who speaks Spanish but
doesn't know he speaks Spanish until he
speaks Spanish and please was like
it was like relief because if we can
make John Cleese laugh you're like no
hear that joke before
the Monty Python seal of approval
[Music]
whale
[Music]
you know the name of the movie I do I do
what it was about I'd
have a script to read because it was not
available to me I heard that it was
based on a play I didn't know what it
was I I really went in like a babe in
the woods really just wanted to to meet
Darren Aronofsky world-class filmmaker
Darren Aronofsky I'm sitting in his
office and he's telling me about he
doesn't know if he's gonna make this
movie or not because
the elements that go into creating this
character needless to say I read the
script of course I got that feeling
again that I got when I was kid when I
got the call you mean I could do this I
mean I it's a possibility I don't know
if I'm going to be able to or not or if
I'm allowed to or if I'm invited to but
the answer is yes I mean it it felt like
it felt like Destiny calling
do you forget
the feeling
coloring capable
capable of not caring
people are amazing you had the ear
markings of everything that I would love
to play in a character he's conflicted
he's infinitely human he's not perfect
there are Dark Shades to Charlie
Charlie's us he's he's just another
person someone who we could easily
dismiss his story is played out behind
closed doors in the dark of a
two-bedroom apartment somewhere in
northern Idaho in his world
he also has a journey of redemption to
go on the
fluidity that Sadie plays this beautiful
controlled rage was breathtaking to me I
was constantly going up on my lines and
that's just because I got cobwebs
upstairs and I was wearing a lot of gear
but also because I was just slack jawed
I'm not joking watching her work she won
the game ball every day we worked I'm
telling you Hong Chow well first of all
hongchao just makes everyone better
around her she elevates the material for
how personal that she makes it there's
some sort of alchemy going on in her
process that makes you believe
everything she does or says it's she
smacks of such authenticity it's it's
astonishing the cast The Crew Darren Sam
Hunters screenplay all respect the
dignity
of who Charlie is in a way that I was
not prepared for I have been since able
to meet and speak with people who have
seen the movie it's a work that I am
confident can change hearts and Minds
I'm astonished I'm I'm happy I'm a
little bit bewildered I'm optimistic I'm
excited to get to know my peers in a
meaningful way I only can think of what
comes to mind when I read the words I
know not all that may come but come what
will
I will go to it laughing that's Herman
Melville
in 1851 it means a lot to me